we begin this morning with President
Trump wrapping up the first of two high
profile summits on his schedule
at the g7 summit in Quebec Canada where
he has been meeting with leaders from
six US allies including Canada France
Britain Germany Italy and Japan the
already fragile relations became even
more strained Friday after mr. Trump
suggested that the group should invite
Russia back to the table four years
after it pushed out Vladimir Putin for
violating international law and that
wasn't all that angered the allies we
Joe Jiang is in Quebec City with the
latest we did a good morning a good
morning the road to the g7 summit was
paved with angry remarks between
President Trump and other leaders
clashing over those new US tariffs on
steel and aluminum imports and even
though there were several displays of
unity here the president has not
indicated he's willing to reverse them
in Quebec Canada president Trump put on
a big smile next to allies who he has
publicly sparred with in recent days
trying to ease the tension with a joke
Justin has agreed to cut all tariffs
barriers between Canada the United
States French president Emmanuel macron
echoed the shift in tone on trade the
reasoning a critical path I suppose a
willingness from all the science to
define agreements and but just hours
before the summit started the leaders
were engaged in a war of words amid
fears of a trade war we are not going to
live with the deals the way they are
European Union treats us very unfairly
Canada very unfairly addressing volatile
disagreements with the US president
McCrone tweeted earlier this week the
American President may not mind being
isolated but neither do we mind signing
a six country agreement if need be and
posted this sharp rebuke seemingly
directed at mr. Trump no leader is
eternal and Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau recently expressed dismay
after President Trump imposed Newt
on Canada Mexico and the EU citing
national security concerns the idea that
we are somehow a national security
threat to the United States is quite
frankly as helping and unacceptable
president Trump provoking US allies
further by calling for Russia's
reinstatement to the group after it
pushed out President Vladimir Putin for
illegally annexing Crimea 2014 they
should let Russia come back in because
we should have Russia at the negotiating
table as of this morning it is still
unclear if the leaders will be signing
that communique with the US president
Trump will also be missing some key
discussions on climate change because
he's leaving here early heading to that
other big summit of course in Singapore
to meet with kim jeong-hoon on tuesday
deena we judge Aang in Quebec City
thanks Rita